it sort of looks like Tulsi gabbard  stole my logo and we've had this logo  for years one of our viewers designed it  it's not the most creative logo but it's  definitely unique to our show in the  news and politics space and all of a  sudden Tulsi gabbard makes a new podcast  leaves the Democratic party and her logo  is the same except with her name instead  of mine now do I think I have the  copyright on italicized slanted text no  but this is a little different than if  like some show about skydiving had a  similar logo this is another news and  politics podcast right in the same space  I don't know how it ended up this way  but it's certainly a little bit weird